you
I posted the video a few days ago
showing ancient Archer which is sort of
a game engine thing I've been playing
with for several weeks and I've learned
a lot just by trying to make a game
engine and I was actually doing a
challenge with some friends to try to
make some quick little games just to get
our feet wet in that a game building
world of a programming and well we've
had a lot of unexpected turns mostly
this I'm mainly spearheading this
project but I couldn't do it without
help so I don't want to take all the
credit
but I do recognize that I am kind of the
the lead on this so to speak so it's
sort of my place to keep it going and
make sure in one way or another things
continue forward and doesn't get
stagnant that's that's my duty as well
as programming of course so I'm working
on this project code and I guess it's
sort of a code name ancient Archer that
really just comes from I don't know what
I was thinking at the time other than I
wanted to get a little arrow shooting in
the proper dynamics of an arrow flying
through the air and it colliding
correctly and all that so I was just
thinking okay if I can maybe get anxious
archery working that'd be a good step
but where this started out is trying to
make like a first-person shooter turn
into okay I kind of want to make tools
to make games and of course the obvious
question is here why would you do that
when there's a Unreal unity Godot and
many others there's so many other
engines to use and I thought about this
a lot and I really don't have that good
of an answer other than I want to know
how to do it I want to know how to make
an engine
so that that's why I'm trying to make my
own and it's from its I don't know how
to explain it other than that really
it's just some highlight building things
from the ground up and I like
understanding things from a really
in-depth level so this gives me that
experience where I kind of have to know
how things work underneath the hood and
that's just what I like so that's why
I'm trying to make my own game engine
rather than using unreal or / unity or
something I have nothing against using
other engines and in fact I'll get to
that a little later so we'll come back
to that topic but I want to talk about
what I've learned here very very
specifically and I'm gonna go through a
little list bear with me for a second my
stick you know it's hopefully I don't
reveal to any anything too too
embarrassing on my list anyway okay so
this this was kind of the plan we had
these ten pseudo games worked out where
we just wanted to spend a week trying to
make each one just to see what would
happen basically so we're trying to make
a tactics game like many tactics or
something a game where you scavenge
around as a rat the game where you just
run endlessly and side-scroller fighter
battle royale MMO plant growing and
plant growing was last week something
started to happen during the MMO week
and the plant growing where he was
basically sort of turning into minecraft
which just was cool on its own right and
really fun
but through this process of trying to
make these games it was a real struggle
had a lot of weeks we were I was able to
hack things together enough to make it
sort of you something playable but I
started to run into roadblocks where
this engine just didn't have support for
something I wanted to do so I would have
to go try to build the support and then
in building support I would sort of get
lost in this this world of am I doing
this the way that makes the most sense
or or should I be doing it some other
way and I'll give you maybe a few
examples might bring in perspective may
open a few classes here so example for
example I have my game got CPP and I
have a global camera in here at global
display now I know like a hundred
percent for sure this is not the best
way of doing it there's no doubt in my
mind but I'm trying to concoct a better
way and it's been like that every step
of the way
just with every little thing with how
I'm gonna load things in without I'm
gonna show text with how I'm gonna do
lighting with how I'm gonna switch
shaders it's just been a constant okay
what's the best way to do this okay how
should I be doing this what wastes
scales away can I reuse and build on its
physics it's a lot of work so the way
this this is sort of intended to be
structured is there's the core engine
which will rarely get edited except when
the whole thing is upgraded or new
features added there's also main gain
which is in theory the main parts you
would edit to make any new game where
you load in all your stuff and set up
your logic sort of thing and the main
loop already has the timing ready and
things like that and there's a third
folder called packages and these are
sort of continued to be plugins or add
in add-ons and they they'll use parts of
the engine
set up things that can work within your
game basically it's like I have a first
person player set up and a GUI master
renderer which is probably going away
because I found a better way to handle
that some font stuff the planter which
is sort of for planting more entities in
the world primitive system and which is
just for drawing squares and circles and
stuff like that a side scroller player a
skybox and it's honor or just so these
were things that like as I was making
the games they had their intended
purposes of fulfilling a role within the
game like for the side scroller fighter
I made the spawner - odd little enemies
and so on but okay once we were doing
seven plant growth where he was
essentially gonna try to make the garden
get plants growing you have to water him
tend to him a little and things like
that and what ended up happening almost
this whole week is I would concoct this
little plan to make a plant and then I
would just notice things that wouldn't
work so well I mean maybe I could kind
of hack them together and sure I could
get a little set of blocks growing to
look like a plan or something but it was
missing a lot of stuff like I wouldn't
sit on the ground right what if you
destroyed the block below it would it
destroy and that sort of architecture
behind the scenes to set up all that was
just basically you'd have to make
another package for that was like the
answer and he got to the point where
just expanding these packages rather
than working on the engine then I was
like okay I kind of need to revisit how
I'm doing things and a big thing for me
was I don't really have any scene
management and I started to notice that
management's pretty big so I started
working on getting more of a world
structure set up and I really have hit a
roadblock here so in my latest branch
which is actually not in this branch
either clay you're just accurate this is
not the latest branch where you are
actually collide the following doesn't
trigger correctly so you walked over
empty spaces jump will fall back down
there's a little logic to work out of
there I've kind of put that on the back
burner basic lighting and texturing
going on later Brady's like to point
like don't want you to get deep
underground you can actually don't do
you think it's just a constant like that
it's approximately the direction though
but guy looks like perfect but actually
I have it backwards so this right now
this is actually going to get worked on
anymore this projects done and destroy
them as well
[Music]
so yeah there's a lot you can do with
this so actually a lot of fun
blocks rendering I'm playing around with
all this getting getting all there
laughs there's layers you can dig down
through eventually lava and walk through
and yeah that's all just set up in this
this main game constructor it loads
everything in builds up the scene real
quick so one thing I had another thing I
wanted to add was some sort of level
loader but it's like I can't really add
a level loader until I know how all my
into these are gonna work I still need a
proper mesh loader and that whole system
and I need a scene management which is
it kind of where I left off so I was
working on a new package called world it
was more like a seem thing where it
brings in all your pieces it's currently
the world is sort of this primitive
renderer thing which makes not a lot of
sense when you the more I think about it
but it encompasses your core shader that
you start with some lights all the
entities all your little primitive
drawing so this is getting changed more
back to a primitive drawler and a lot of
the stuffs being abstracted out and
gonna be seen managed so maybe asking
all right what's the point of this video
that's basically to kind of document the
amount of work it takes to even start a
game engine it's just the amount of
thought it takes to to organize
everything in the amount of
restructuring and that you have to
actually try to build stuff with it just
see where you're at and to see what's
working what isn't it because if you're
not making stuff with it then well it's
not exactly a game engine I guess but
this this is my experience so far so
what I'm actually doing are next week
this week is space shooter bullet hell
game we're calling this project Chronos
javelin so they'll have a demo of that
Sunday I mean
something I don't know how good it's
going to be but this week they're gonna
step back from this engine and the work
I've been putting into it and I'm gonna
go we're gonna go to unreal I'm gonna go
to unreal friends are gonna follow me on
to unreal here and help out so hopefully
we can get that space shooter going on
their old Kronos javelin and it's gonna
be very simplistic of course in the
first week but if it's something we
really enjoy might continue but this I I
need this experience at this point
because I want to see how they do things
and we'll probably try some with unity
too and see how they do things and feel
for it as eventually you know a best
practice as a best practice I'm probably
missing some stuff just because I
haven't used other game engines of fun I
I guess I come from a world of
programming where I kind of learned old
school in a way that's kind of just how
Ohio University started with it just
straight from the console logic
programming computer science style they
never really get into using many tools
and stuff it was like you got a no go
logic behind it and that's still what
intrigued me and that's sort of why I've
avoided game engines uh other game
engines and one film have another reason
there it's just I wanted to know the
inner workings I guess already said
that's what it's not really another
reason but maybe he explains my train of
thought a little bit so it's something
so that's where I'm at here as of this
day where we had June June 19th
it's 240 something in the morning seems
like a crazy hour to be up but it's not
that bad actually because I slept from
like 7 o'clock to midnight I got off
work and just hard crash
so tired we're tired and realized but
now I'm late in kind of wait a week so
how to do this video I was on my mind
and just give a little documentation of
what's going on here no this is also
using my engine here's all using OpenGL
and that's just because it's it's easy
to get going with some libraries it's
becoming apparent to me that I need to
support more things with my engine do
but I think for now I'm gonna stick with
just open jail for a while and later oh
look at my maybe adding support for
other OS ISM and for DirectX right now
it's just windows only OpenGL I'm sure
you could get it running on Linux too
I just have to do a little messing with
the build files I've no doubt in my mind
that I keep this all running on Linux
pretty easily but yeah all right well
that'll do it for this video
you got this far consider subscribing
and even the bail or notifications to
keep updated on things also puso about
random how-to videos so that's kind of
the name of this channel in code technic
Toro they just want to talk about code
technology and maybe do some tutorials
here and there so it's gonna be
peppering of things and also just some
of my personal experiences so you can
probably find links in me and some of
other videos and that in my description
if you want to follow me personally I'm
not gonna post any of my friends that
are helping out because I haven't asked
them are posting any of their links you
know world-weary new with this at this
point - so alright well you have a good
evening
date night whatever it is for you and
i'll see you in the next video